Way out past Neptune, New Horizons is flying
through the attic of our solar system… where
we keep all the ancient building blocks of
life and planets.
How do we know?
Because we can see red.
Hello dwarf planet fans, Ian here for DNews,
taking some time to check in on NASA’s most
daring space probe that’s currently digging
deep into some of the solar system’s most
ancient artifacts.
After launching in 2006, NASA’s New Horizons
mission took nearly a decade to reach the
outer solar system to fly past Pluto.
Then the nuclear-powered spacecraft zipped
through Pluto's system and saw many strange
and wonderful things.
Probably the biggest shocker was Pluto has
a kind of rusty color.
Mars now has some competition!
Who would have guessed Pluto would be the
second “red planet” located in the solar
system’s badlands -- way out there in the
Kuiper Belt.
This is surprising because up until 2015,
astronomers only had a very blurry, fuzzy
idea about what the tiny world looked like.
We thought it was an icy rocky body, but there’s
so much more...
Data is still being beamed back to Earth from
that famous flyby and planetary scientists
have been blown away by the incredible discoveries
that have been made.
Although Pluto is located almost 40 times
further away from the sun than the Earth,
it is far from being a frozen, static wasteland;
it has vast plains of slow-moving ices, wondrous
mountain ranges and it even has a thin atmosphere
that appears to create wispy clouds above
its surface!
Its system of moons ARE also rich and varied
tiny worlds in their own right.
It's cold, but it's not boring.
The reason Pluto is red, it seems, has something
to do with tholins!
Tholins are an organic compound.
They can form the backbone of amino acids,
and while they’re not life as such, they
are certainly organic molecules!
Scientists think that the tholins on Pluto’s
surface are formed when ultraviolet light
from the sun breaks down methane and nitrogen
in the dwarf planet’s thin atmosphere.
These tholins then rained down turning its
surface a browny red.
From an astrobiology standpoint, tholins are
really interesting as they are a critical
ingredient for life as we know it.
And the fact New Horizons has found Pluto
is covered in the stuff underscores the surprisingly
active atmospheric chemistry that’s going
on super far away from the sun.
No one really expected this stuff to happen
on Pluto!
The more you think about it, the more confusing
it can get, because tholins can't form in
Earth's atmosphere.
Instead, we may have had tholins delivered
to us by comets and asteroids, possibly forming
the backbone of life here billions of years
ago.
So even though New Horizons already flew by
Pluto, there's a lot more to learn.
It’s now on track to make an EVEN CLOSER
flyby of another object deep in the Kuiper
Belt called 2014 MU69.
And, MU69 is even redder than Pluto!
Scientists will be absolutely checking to
see if its redness is also caused by the presence
of tholins.
MU69 is ancient, and has occupied the Kuiper
Belt since the dawn of the solar system.
If this little frozen red rock is also covered
in tholins, then it too may have these building
blocks for life.
But what does that mean?
We talked to the New Horizons team and they
said we won't know until we get there.
We are truly at the raggedy edge of science
discovery, where a robotic probe is pushing
deep into the unexplored Kuiper belt and also
deep into the ancient history of our solar
system.
Life on Earth may have come from space, but
how did THAT work?
Check out my recent video about comets carrying
the chemistry of life and a cool planet-hopping
life hypothesis called panspermia!
Should these impacts have been powerful enough,
chunks of Earth's crust would've been kicked
into space.
As the planet is covered in life, some of
these chunks of Earth rock would've likely
had bacteria hitching a ride.
What other secrets do you think Pluto's hiding?
Let us know in the comments below and like
and subscribe and come back for more DNews
every day of the week.